according hi my name is more fires a
Pakistani origin of turned away from
Islam 28 years ago I am a practicing
Christian I am trying to highlight the
races of behavior and the Islamic
ideology which led to the rapes of white
girls across 28 towns in the UK
connection question I think in middle
England there was a Pakistani man who
converted to Christianity and she was
attacked attacked it's nice are you
saying a friend of mine have you had any
experience in violence I have been
living amongst the white community for
the past 20 years had I done what mr.
Singh did openly stayed dead I won't be
alive now it's because I'm staying
outside the Islamic communities having
said that now that my face is out there
it's only a matter of time before they
find me at the moment I am a one step
ahead of them I do know that they are
looking for me because I am exposing the
racist behavior that I exist within the
Pakistani Muslim communities not the
Pakistani Christian communities but the
Pakistani Muslim communities my friend
is a Pakistani Muslim and she grew up as
a mixed-race child and a Pakistani
household and because she because she
was half white and she was demonized she
said the racism within the Pakistani
community towards white people is off
the charts as unbelievable as this
exists from Pakistanis not from weights
I've been without white community for
the past 28 years under the
kind for my people now the problem we
have here for example Quilliam
foundation in 3% of the Pakistani men
population in the UK 84 percent are
responsible for the grooming gang grid
for white girls I want to add to that I
want to say this that 3 percent of the
Pakistani Muslim population in this
country out of which eighty four percent
are racist all the white guys our major
problem that we need to tackle you need
to be excused and yeah it's them that
still eat up the whites especially the
white women has been slag done [__] but
you have to look at the ratio you know
if Pakistanis are between five to seven
percent of the British population why as
you said eighty seven percent of them
erasing groomers before illumise that a
statistic is off the chart you know but
that is a donor with intensive research
by a Muslim themselves from the Quilliam
foundation so is this color to a
religious why is it well I think if it's
cultural for example let's say if it's
cultural then how come that the
Pakistani Christians are not raping
white girls because it's the same
culture why is that the reason is
because it's got nothing to do with
culture is everything to do with Islamic
ideally ideology the exactly in a moral
example that Mohammed said in the first
place
yes that is not help it's not help just
an example that he said about these
people take from ya so because we never
asked meets our Muslim no CEO will see
will these rates that the not is the
cultural they're not Islamic is there a
basis isn't in Islam with Ferrari will
you torture reap when you grew up
come on I mean as I said if it's to do
with that it would cultural then why is
it that the Pakistani Christians are not
raping yeah it's the same culture yeah
why aren't they are doing the same
well the simple reason is it's not
cultural it's the way that Islamic
mentality thinks because of that text
because of Mohammed why he did with HOH
was nine years old when I was being
raised up in them within that community
we're taught white people filthy dirty
feet Pig
women are slides asleep and randomly ask
for it if this is the attitudes that we
are brought up with and Mohammed's on
example it doesn't help either it is no
wonder that we are raping yeah the last
thing I would see is if you could if he
could it be religious or look to some
kind of religious leader Alberta before
Jesus or Buddha
you know Jesus is all about forgiveness
Brotherhood lightness acceptance love
Mohammed is about slaughtered war rape
booty you know everything isn't too
jolly I mean anything that he in wanted
that he said Allah said and it if you
look at the ten
Commandments Mahmoud broke every single
one of them especially for example
adultery when he went to his adopted son
and said I want your wife because Allah
has has ordained it unbelievable
anything he wanted Allah said he could
have and the cold that's not a cultic
figure not a prophet
do you believe Muhammad existed I
believe professors don't I believe well
even if he did or I can't this born
around them well even if he did or
didn't that isn't the point the point is
that the guy has made a terrible
terrible impact throughout the 1,400
years thank you so much for the same
thank you very much ok no